joining us now from Washington is dr.
Jerome Adams he is the US Surgeon
General he is a member of the White
House coronavirus task force we've seen
him on TV a lot these days dr. Adams
it's good to see you thank you for
joining us you know well it's really
good to be here Gail and I appreciate
the segment you just played we really
want people to understand that it's
about preparation but not panic and that
you can't build a toilet-paper fortress
that's going to keep people are a little
freaked out they're a little panicked
and it's not just the stores that are
running low we keep hearing stories
about hospitals that may not be well
equipped what are you saying or what are
you doing to make sure that the
hospitals have everything that they need
well we have the National strategic
stockpile that has been around for years
and that we're always keeping keeping
updated keeping maintained so that when
states have specific shortages we can
respond to those but we're also looking
on the demand side and we're having
conversations with the American Hospital
Association American College of Surgeons
put out a statement this weekend telling
people that look talk to your doctor if
you've got an elective surgery planned
now maybe not be the best time to have
that elective procedure done because it
uses up personal protective equipment it
potentially brings in coronavirus click
cases into the hospital and it taxes
health care workers so we're trying to
lower the demand while also increasing
the supply of critical materials and
resources dr. the administration is
putting out new guidance today can you
give us any any idea of where where
things might be headed well we are at a
critical inflection point in this
country we have the same number of cases
that Italy had two weeks ago and so
we've got a choice to make that we want
to follow the trajectory of a South
Korea where they had aggressive
mitigation measures and everyone really
leaned into this issue or do we want to
follow the trajectory of Italy where
we're seeing a rapid increase in cases
and more deaths and so the CDC put out
guidelines just this morning saying that
we should no longer have large
gatherings of more than 50 people we
really are all in this together and we
want people to think about social
isolation social distancing and so that
we can make sure that coronavirus isn't
being spread in our community doc doctor
you bring up a great point I mean it is
social distancing and social isolation
as a recommendation enough or do we need
to get ahead of the Italy situation by
federally-mandated at bars restaurants
and other leisure activities shut down
until this passes well it's important to
understand that a lot of that authority
in the United States live at the state
and the local level and I know this is
someone who used to work for a both a
local health department and a state
house that is certainly true but but the
federal government has a lot of
leadership capability and if it said so
it might be done it would give a lot of
cover at a local politician so federally
should there be let me agree with you
completely agree with you and that's why
the CDC put out the guidance this
morning that's why the president
declared an emergency last week and
that's why you saw the tweet from me
this weekend saying hospital systems
should pull down and their elective
cases went when appropriate when they
consider the hospital's doctor to the
hospitals have enough supplies some of
them are saying they're concerned or our
hospitals ready for this well again we
are leaning into the stockpile we're
increasing purchases we're working with
companies like 3m to make sure we can
make more masks available and there will
be issues that pop up across the country
and that's what the stockpile is for
what about ventilators do they have
enough ventilators well as of right now
we have enough ventilators when you look
at different modeling projections there
are scenarios where we potentially
wouldn't have enough ventilators but the
way that you make sure you have enough
ventilators is to decrease the number of
people who need them by leaning into
these aggressive mitigation measures
that we're talking about can we talk
about people on the frontlines just this
morning in Washington State a dog
emergency room doctors tested positive
he's now in critical condition what is
your message to them to the to the
healthcare workers who are on the
frontlines well I so much appreciate you
asking that we need to take care of the
people who take care of the people and I
really feel like this weekend at the
press conference when we announced our
new testing strategy that we've made a
turning point on testing and you'll see
that we prioritized among the groups to
be tested health care workers we've got
to make sure they're safe and that they
feel safe we've got to make sure they
have the PPE they need we've got to make
sure we're not unnecessarily exposing
them into potential coronavirus cases
with elective procedures that could be
delayed PPE what's that
you know protective equipment gloves
gowns masks the things that we know keep
people safe from coronavirus all right
all right very good dr. Adams we
appreciate you being here I hope you
come back again soon Thank You
coronavirus gov or your State Department
of Health website or great resources for
people out there
thank you very much